now greater manchester has launched a
new campaign to try to tackle sexual
harassment of women and girls in public
spaces the is this okay initiative is
aimed at men and boys and looks to
challenge problematic attitudes and
behaviors in society
hey beautiful because of smile they
almost preach you when you smile
all right don't ignore me
come on boys
i think you're better than me yeah
you're not even that fit you're not
gonna let me know you're asking for it
dressed like that
tonight i should definitely walk soon
are you sexy
do you think this is okay
well the mayor of greater manchester
andy burnham told sky news that it's
time to end the harassment of women and
girls
last year we had some awful appalling
tragic
murders of women
sarah everard but there were other cases
as well and there was an outpouring of
frustration and uh
just just
complete distress from women all over
the country and to be honest
i thought and listened more about this
issue and listened more than if i'm
honest i ever had that before and what i
heard was the public debate was in
completely the wrong place particularly
the message coming from police and
public authorities saying or women
should do this to protect themselves or
they should do the other and of course
the issue is with men lads and boys
isn't it that that's where we need to
start and that's where this campaign
grew from that recognition that this
one's on men lads and boys we've got to
own it we're the ones who need to make
changes
and that's what the is this okay
campaign is all about we're going to
take the is this okay campaign into
schools colleges and communities in 2022
this video is just the starting point
but already it has prompted a huge
conversation uh across the country and
we're really pleased about that uh
people really engaged with it the video
we produced has had over three million
views and that tells you that something
uh is needed here people are crying out
for this uh conversation and i think the
vast majority uh of men and boys are
decent people and perhaps sometimes we
may not realize how behavior may impact
on girls and women and it's about
that honest conversation isn't it uh and
making sure that people understand how
you know what can seem
sort of fairly normal behave or innocent
beggar actually isn't uh when you
consider its effect on other people so
that's what the campaign is all about it
is about education
and an honest debate that i don't think
we've had before and i don't think i'm
the only
uh man who's saying that to be honest
i've not thought as much about these
things as i should and i'm not saying
i'm not lecturing anybody here i'm
simply saying this one's on all of us
and we do need not to take
responsibility for it